we're taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
let's go to our next caller from the
7:20 area code caller what's your name
and where are you calling from today
great what's on your mind so I wanted to
ask you what New York okay so let's just
give me one second I can barely hear you
so let we're gonna turn you up on our
end but also I think your cell reception
maybe is going in and out let's try it
from the top once more I heard fake news
I wanted to see what you thought the
difference was between fake news and
propaganda ok yeah increasingly people
are even emailing me about this saying
the term fake news has become confused
and sort of perverted or subverted in
some way and we should be distinguishing
between fake news and propaganda news if
I were to make such a distinction and I
think there's a distinction to make and
and you know with all these terms like
regressive left for example the original
intent of the phrase ends up getting
perverted for me fake news is flat-out
made-up stories it can include satirical
news so like for me the onion is a fake
and use website it's it's obvious satire
they're making up the stories it's meant
to either be funny or make an
interesting point or some combination of
the two I would also consider part of
fake news the websites that I've read so
much about at this point which also are
created maybe not a satire but they're
just making up stories they're making up
stories for ad dollars whatever
propaganda news is different from that
in that it is actually more connected to
a real story so to speak but the
implications background hyperbole and
speculation push it from being a news
story into a propaganda story so an
example of that might be you take some
obscure comment
the efficient official from some
government agency and you turn it into a
headline that completely changes the
meaning of what a government official
might have said and you connect to that
hyperbolic statements about you know
tyranny or something like that and and
I'm getting kind of specific here but
that to me is propaganda news and I
consider it different from fake news but
to be honest I don't know that the
average person is even keyed into the
difference between the two well that's
that's very interesting so when can I
ask a follow-up question please yeah so
what do you think of the larger fake
news industry you were recently on the
Jessie Peterson program I think it was
yeah I'm not sure if you're aware of
this it's owned by Genesis
communications network which is owned by
Teddy Anderson which also owns Alex
Jones and a lot of very similar programs
you know I want to take issue with one
aspect you're saying I just want to take
issue with one aspect I know that the
Jesse Lee Peterson show and the Alex
Jones radio show are distributed in a
syndication way by Genesis but I don't
know that Genesis owns the shows i
understanding as Genesis is the radio
distributor of those shows but that the
shows are independently owned ah so what
do you think then about distributors
that's collect to specifically
distribute propaganda and fake news it's
it's a business for them you know I mean
they're choosing shows they can make
money with these are for-profit
companies and we can pass moral or
ethical judgment on them but hey this is
their business their job is to just put
the shows on stations bring in
advertisers and take a piece of that
revenue so I could sort of make a moral
judgement about it but this is their
business and that's what they're doing
and they're probably relatively agnostic
to the propaganda status of the programs
that they distribute thanks really
important I we may do more on the
distinction between fake and propaganda
news so I'm glad you brought it up
always great to hear from our friends in
Denver and I really
I appreciate the call that is gonna do
it for today some very very interesting
phone calls we will take calls again it
will happen again I promise you we will
take a break facebook.com slash David
Pakman show make sure to give us a like
on Facebook